this June Netflix is boosting the
quantity and quality of their streaming
selections they're rolling out nearly
three dozen new original movies and
shows including the highly anticipated
second seasons of Luke Cage and glow
along with the series finale of cult
hits since eight plus look for brand new
action-packed blockbusters to land on
the streaming service this month here's
everything coming to Netflix in June
2018 starting with the Netflix originals
busted season finale Netflix is
off-the-wall Korean detective comedy
busted premiered throughout May with
each Friday seeing the release of two
new episodes viewers have had plenty of
time to get invested in this motley crew
of celebrity detectives as they work to
gather clues and unravel mysteries then
June first heralds the arrival of the
season finale finally bringing closure
to all those quirky antics November 13
attack on Paris November 13 2015 was a
tragic day in Paris terror has
perpetrated a series of bombings and
mass shootings in the French capital
that ultimately took 130 lives to say
that the horrific incidents affected
many in Paris would be an understatement
and that's the focus of Netflix's
documentary series November 13 attack on
Paris through three gripping episodes
the series we'll explore the terrorist
attacks and their emotional aftermath
through candid interviews with French
citizens as well as first responders
look for it on June 1st the break with
Michelle wolf comedian Michelle Wolf's
brand-new sketch comedy and late-night
show premiered on May 27th and will
continue throughout June with new
episodes each week starting on June 3rd
tune in every Sunday as wolf sits down
with celebrity guests and take shots at
politics modern life and everything in
between
Alex strangelove Alex is a high school
boy with a perfect life who decides that
he's finally ready to go all the way
with his girlfriend but when he meets a
boy who makes him question everything he
realizes that his life may not be so
perfect after all look for it on June
8th Ali's wedding this award-winning
Australian comedy drama follows a Muslim
man named Ali who finds himself caught
between a rock and a hard place
or rather caught between his family and
the woman he loves starring comedian
Osama Samy and based on Sammy's own
memoir Ali's wedding is sure to be an
emotional crowd-pleaser look for it to
hit Netflix on June 8 March Ella season
2 the first season of this British
detective series aired two glowing
views and Netflix picked up the
international rights immediately
starring Onofrio March Ella is about a
retired detective who rejoins the force
in a state of personal crisis after her
husband decides to divorce her and take
the kids after she picks up a 15 year
old murder investigation March Ella
slowly finds that her own life may be
inextricably linked to the killer season
2 of March Ella aired in Britain
starting in February 2018 and will be
making its way to Netflix on June 8th
since eight the series finale this
Netflix original sci-fi series is
practically a legend at this point after
two seasons Netflix cancelled since 8:00
in 2017 claiming that it wasn't bringing
in enough viewers to justify its
exorbitant cost rumoured to be 9 million
dollars per episode in season 2 someone
gave me just when the dust had all
cleared fans were left with a massive
cliffhanger and an insatiable urge for
more sensate leading to a flood of
online petitions to put the show back on
the air it seems like someone in Netflix
has heard the cries for more and a
two-hour series finale is finally slated
to land on Netflix On June 8th the
staircase in 2001 novelist Michael
Peterson called the police to report
that his wife Kathleen had fallen down
the stairs the ensuing police
investigation honed in on Peterson as
the prime suspect and in 2003 Peterson
was sentenced to life in prison for the
crime injuries are not consistent with a
fall down the stairs
Netflix's upcoming documentary series
the staircase takes a deep dive into the
details of the controversial case did
Peterson do it was it an accident was
she attacked by an owl follow all the
twists and turns when the staircase
shows up on June 8 lust stories this
anthology series explores life and love
in India through the lens of four
different filmmakers each presenting a
different film about relationships trust
in betrayal basically the title says it
all
look for it on June 15th Maktub an
Israeli dramedy this film sees two
bumbling criminals decide to change
their lives after surviving a terrorist
bombing armed with a new purpose in life
they set out to make wishes come true
specifically by nabbing people's written
prayers from Jerusalem's Wailing Wall
together they go on a chaotic journey as
they try to learn how to be good people
look for Maktub on June 15th set it up
things get wild and set it up when to
corporate lackeys decide to try to get
their high-strung
bosses to fall in love when they're
boning we're free
but when things inevitably go wrong with
their matchmaking plan they start
finding out that they have more in
common with each other than they thought
set it up premieres on Netflix on June
15th Sundays illness described as an
aching sweeping drama Sunday's illness
is the emotional story of a mother and
her estranged daughter who spent ten
days at an isolated cabin together there
they slowly tried to come to terms with
where their lives are now and how things
could have been different experience the
whole journey when Sunday's illness
arrives on June 15th the ranch part five
Netflix is sitcom the ranch has fallen
on some hard times
following continued allegations against
actor and co-executive producer Danny
Masterson Netflix decided to write
master since character out of the ranch
and continue without him still the
series is plowing ahead into its third
season with Ashton Kutcher Sam Elliott
and Debra Winger reprising their roles
the first part of the new season drops
on June 15 club-date Cuervos presents
the Ballad of Hugo Sanchez the Mexican
drama club de Cuervos doesn't seem like
it has the makings of a cult classic but
give it a chance because there are a lot
of good surprises here centering on the
brother and sister owners of the Cuervos
football club the series is a perfect
mix of drama crime thrills and comedy
now the series is producing its first
spin-off which translates to the ballot
of Hugo Sanchez and follows series
regular Hugo Sanchez on his own
storyline within the Cuervos universe
take a look on June 17 brain on fire
based on journalist Susanna Collins
autobiography brain on fire my month of
madness the film follows the bizarre
events which saw a Holland suffer an
apparent mental breakdown that was later
diagnosed to be the symptoms of an
autoimmune disease Chloe grace Moretz
stars as Colin with an impressive list
of co-stars that includes Richard
Armitage and carrie-anne moss
don't miss brain on fire when it lands
on June 22nd Darren brown miracle hot on
the heels of his Netflix special to push
illusionist and Mentalist
Darren brown is back with miracle this
time Brown is taking to the stage to
subtly poke fun at blind religious
beliefs even as he seemingly performs
the same impossible stunts that would
push someone to believe in a higher
power in the first place
your ability to read just felt long
enough to teach you a powerful lesson
it's sure to be a head trip so tune in
to get your mind blown on June 22nd
heavy rescue 401 season two tow trucks
fire trucks semi trucks there are big
trucks everywhere in heavy rescue 401 if
you were a kid who liked trucks and who
grew up to like trucks even more you're
bound to love this show about trucks
there's the door for you transport truck
I get my truck right here
right along with the guys who operate
rescue vehicles as they brave the
harshest environment imaginable Ontario
season - revs into gear on June 22nd
marvels Luke Cage season 2 can anyone
believe it's been over a year and a half
since season one of Luke Cage first
arrived on Netflix time flies when
you're in denial but the wait is finally
over this time Luke Cage is facing off
against the new villain Bushmaster the
unbreakable hero is set to reappear on
Netflix on June 22nd don't miss it
secret city filled with high stakes
thrills and political intrigue secret
city follows a journalist who gets too
close to the truth and uncovers a web of
conspiracies starring on a tour of and
Jacki Weaver Netflix describes this
upcoming show as dark and cerebral which
sounds like a grand old time look for it
on June 26th glow season 2 Saturday
Night's Alright for fighting this June
with an all-new season of the hit series
glow we got a show to do what is this
the gorgeous ladies of wrestling make
their triumphant return in the ring on
June 29th kiss me first
in the near future a young woman who's
addicted to a popular virtual reality
game meets a mysterious woman who shows
her how dark the game can actually get
with a hook like that there's no doubt
that kiss me first will turn out to be a
popular addition to Netflix as lineup
look for it on June 29th nailed it
season 2 how many ways are there to make
a bad cake at least another season's
worth nailed it season 2 is preheating
the oven for another round of culinary
monstrosities in the poor folk who are
just trying their best take a bite on
June 29th recovery boys from Alain
McMillion Sheldon the director of the
oscar-nominated documentary heroin
recovery boys takes a long painful look
into the opioid epidemic focusing on
four men who are struggling to recover
from addiction and reenter society cue
it up On June 29th Tao the sci-fi
thriller Tao
stars michael monroe gary oldman and
heads crime the movie sees crime put on
his Deadpool pants again as shady
supervillain Ajax sorry Alex who kidnaps
a young grifter named Julia and subjects
her to a dangerous experiment escape
seems impossible since she's being
guarded by Tao and advanced artificial
intelligence developed by Alex take a
look on June 29th original stand-up
comedy with only two new stand-up
specials to boast in June Netflix is
doubling down on quality over quantity
on the comedy front both arrive late in
the month Anna Gadsby Nanette shows up
on the 19th and a special from w kamau
Bell which takes center stage on the
26th that's it for the Netflix originals
now let's turn to everything else
arriving on Netflix this June new movies
Netflix is blowing up the screen this
June with two of 2017 s biggest action
blockbusters Thor Ragnarok which sees
Thor and the Hulk teaming up to save
Asgard from hella and Star Wars the last
Jedi haven't seen him yet you'll get
your chance when Thor arrives on the
fifth and the last Jedi shows up on the
26th
I told a new friend Plus relive some of
the decades best dramas with the
departed arriving on June 1st the King's
Speech on June 2nd and The Imaginarium
of Doctor Parnassus on June 15th
followed by Martin McDonagh czar ever in
2008 crime comedy in Bruges on the 16th
if I grown up on a farm and was [ __ ]
Bruges might impress me but I didn't so
it doesn't in the mood for lighter fare
Netflix is opening the month with some
great new romantic comedies on the first
look for Nick and Norah's Infinite
Playlist rumor has it and just friends
also on the first keep your eyes peeled
for the 2015 documentary he named me
Malala a gripping look at the life of
the youngest Nobel laureate in history
finally Netflix isn't scaring up a ton
of new thrills this month but there are
a few gems hiding in the mix June 1st
will see the edition of taking lives the
Covenant and the boy a selection
guaranteed to keep you up all night new
television you'll be glued to the TV
this June as plenty of new seasons of
fan favorite shows join the Netflix
roster season 2 of Winona Earth drops on
June 9th season 8 of Portlandia On June
10th and on June 16th hold on tight for
the emotional final season of Grey's
Anatomy Plus be sure to check out the
first season Marlon Wayans new sitcom
Marlon on the 14th finally Supergirl
season 3 and iZombie season 4 are slated
to arrive once they finish airing on the
CW and Marvel's agents of shield drops
its 5th season on June 17th that's a
whole lot of excitement for one month
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
you